together my wife for six years she knows
I like to drink I've cut back mostly a
social drinks she doesn't however know
that I do cocaine
weekly it doesn't affect the right
that's weekly it doesn't affect my
day-to-day I've never prioritized the
use of alcohol or anything else I
sometimes feel guilty for not telling
her my last relationship where I was a
super open book never worked I feel it's
my healthiest relationship because we
don't impose knowing every detail but
are still best friends well dude no name
here a home here now he says uh you have
burgeoning addictive pathology here it's
not bad I mean you're sort of you're
starting to get some momentum with
alcohol and cocaine and it is affecting
your life and yet you still can't stop
that's how you measure addiction not So
Much by how much you use but by its
effect on you and in spite of the effect
it continues to roll on
[Music]